This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。绝对真人。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇异的现代世界里，我将为你剖析精神韧性、体能以及培养复原力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字就是数字2。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如在谈到80年代时请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔。1984年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不安全，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着盔甲出行。它向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你听播客的地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控育有一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。需要大批互联网侦探出动，才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子彻底炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of your 20s. So a few weeks ago, I got a DM from one of you, the listeners, about a really toxic workplace. This listener, and she's given me permission to talk about her story, she told me about how she had recently quit a job that she'd had for two years. And she said to me, this job felt more like a terrible relationship than a job, than a way of making money. And she was telling me all these details about how her managers would call her after work hours to get her to respond to feedback. They would ask her to work weekends to do the tasks that, like, they were
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。无论你是新听友还是老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将在节目中剖析你二十多岁的心理。几周前，我收到了一位听众发来的私信，内容是关于一个非常糟糕的工作场所。这位听众（她已经同意让我讲述她的故事）告诉我，她最近辞掉了一份干了两年的工作。她对我说，与其说这是一份工作，不如说这段工作更像是一段糟糕的恋爱关系，而不只是一种赚钱的方式。她向我讲述了所有这些细节，比如她的经理会在下班后打电话给她，让她回复反馈。他们会要求她周末加班来完成那些，比如说，他们
unable to do, saying that this was all part of her job description, this is what she signed up for, and at the same time, she wasn't really getting any perks. She was getting paid very poorly. They wouldn't invite her to any of, like, the workplace events. They would, like, criticize her openly in front of other employees, like, terrible, terrible things. And she quit that job three months ago. And in that period of time, she's been looking for a new job. And she has found that, you know, even applying for new jobs, even looking through new job applications would make her anxious, going into job interviews would make her panic, would make her want to cry, run away, escape. And this all led her to believe that, you know, maybe her previous job had caused her
自己做不完的任务，还说这都是她职位描述的一部分，这是她自己选择的，与此同时她并没有得到什么实质的好处。她的薪水非常低。他们不会邀请她参加任何类似公司聚会的活动。他们会在其他员工面前公开批评她，诸如此类，非常非常糟糕的事情。三个月前她辞掉了那份工作。在那段时间里，她一直在找新工作。她发现，你知道的，甚至连申请新工作、浏览新的招聘信息都会让她感到焦虑，去参加面试会让她恐慌，让她想哭、想逃跑、想逃离。这一切让她开始相信，你知道的，也许之前的那份工作给她造成了
like a degree of trauma and reading her messages. I had to agree with her. And I realized that that there are probably a lot of other people going through this right now, and yet we haven't done an episode on how to deal with this situation, how to deal with a really toxic workplace. We talk a lot on this podcast about finding your calling, how to accelerate at work, how to navigate career anxiety, but we haven't really spoken about what to do when you have a great job, you have maybe your dream job. You finally found a sustainable, secure profession. And it turns out that the workplace that you've walked into is incredibly toxic.
某种程度的创伤。读着她的信息，我不得不赞同她的看法。我意识到，现在可能还有很多人正在经历这一切，然而我们却一直没有做过一期节目来探讨如何应对这种情况，如何应对一个非常糟糕的工作场所。在这个播客中，我们经常谈论如何找到你的使命、如何在工作中取得飞跃、如何应对职业焦虑，但我们其实没有谈过，当你拥有一份好工作、甚至可能是你的梦想工作时，该怎么办。你终于找到了一份可持续、有保障的职业。结果却发现，你踏入的工作场所竟然极其糟糕。
Now you're kind of in that state where you're dreading going to work. Your confidence is shattered. You want to quit, but you don't have the means. You don't know how. And this is exactly what I want to discuss today. It's something that a lot of us go through during the early days of our career, especially in our 20s. and how do we survive a terrible job, but also not just how do we survive when we're currently in it,
现在你陷入了那种害怕去上班的状态。你的自信心粉碎。你想辞职，但你没有那个经济条件。你不知道该怎么做。这正是我今天要讨论的内容。这是我们很多人在职业生涯早期、特别是二十多岁时都会经历的事情。我们该如何在糟糕的工作中生存下来，不仅是如何在身处其中时生存下来，
how do we move on from that experience and kind of find a job that respects you and that you love? Work is a massive part of our identity. So when it's going wrong, it's hard for other things to not be going wrong as well. I've had experiences like this and I'll share one of those experiences that I've had later on because it really can lead us, you know, leave us to be quite broken for lack of a better word. And there is also, of course, a lot of evidence for this being the case. And whilst there is a lot of evidence, there is little acknowledgement of that evidence. So a lot of the time we might be in this situation thinking that we're overreacting,
我们又该如何走出这段经历，找到一份尊重你并且你热爱的工作？工作是我们身份中极其重要的一部分。所以当工作出问题时，其他事情很难不出问题。我也有过这样的经历，稍后我会分享其中一次经历，因为这确实会引导我们，怎么说呢，让我们变得相当崩溃。而且，当然，也有很多证据表明事实确实如此。尽管有大量的证据，但对这些证据的认可却很少。所以很多时候，我们可能会身处这种境地，觉得自己反应过度了，
thinking that we're being dramatic. But time and time again, we see studies, case studies, surveys, polls that show that a lot of people experience this during their lifetime and also it impacts them greatly. So we're going to discuss all of that evidence and the psychology that links toxic workplaces to our psychology and our mental health, how to tell if your workplace is toxic, the different types of toxicity at a job, and also, of course, again, how to survive and how to thrive afterwards. I have a number of tips to share. I have a number of lived experiences to share as well. So if you can relate to having a seriously traumatic former job, former boss,
觉得自己太戏剧化了。但一次又一次，我们看到各种研究、案例研究、调查和民意测验显示，很多人在生平中都经历过这种情况，而且它对他们的影响极深。因此，我们将讨论所有这些证据，以及将有毒的工作场所与我们的心理和心理健康联系起来的心理学，如何判断你的工作场所是否有毒，工作中的不同毒性类型，当然，还有如何生存以及如何在事后蓬勃发展。我有很多小贴士要分享。我也有很多亲身经历要分享。所以，如果你能感同身受，曾经或正在经历一份严重带创伤的前工作、前老板、
current job, current boss, current workplace, stay with us without further ado. Let's get into toxic workplaces. Experiencing a toxic workplace or a toxic work environment takes a huge and an unspoken toll on our mental well-being. And it really does actually surprise me how little we tend to discuss this fact. We talk a lot about relationship trauma, friendship trauma, experiences with mental health or with physical illness, but work is also a significant pillar of our life. But, you know, when we have a toxic relationship with our workplace or in a work environment, we don't really speak about how negatively formative it can be. You know, when that is not going well, it begins to affect everything else. But you kind of feel silly,
现在的工作、现在的老板、现在的工作场所，请留下来，废话不多说。让我们进入有毒的工作场所。经历一个有毒的工作场所或有毒的工作环境，会给我们的心理健康带来巨大且无法言说的代价。事实上，我们往往很少讨论这个事实，这确实让我感到惊讶。我们经常谈论亲密关系创伤、友情创伤、心理健康或身体疾病的经历，但工作也是我们生活中的一个重要支柱。但是，你知道，当我们与工作场所或在工作环境中建立起有毒的关系时，我们其实并不讨论它会产生多么负面的塑造作用。你知道，当那一切进展不顺时，它开始影响其他的一切。但你会觉得自己有点傻，
talking about it, you feel silly having to explain it. You know, everyone's job sucks. No one likes to work. But I want to assure you right now, a toxic workplace does bring a certain kind of emotional experience and it is not an easy thing to go through. To really kind of, you know, examine and illustrate why that is, consider this recent statistic from Gettysburg College in the US. This statistic suggests that you and I, we are probably going to spend around
谈论它时觉得傻，解释它时也觉得傻。你知道的，每个人的工作都很烂。没有人喜欢工作。但我现在向你保证，一个有毒的工作场所确实会带来某种特殊的情感体验，经历这一切绝对不是一件容易的事。为了真正地，你知道的，审视和说明为什么会这样，考虑一下美国葛底斯堡学院的这份最新统计数据。该统计数据表明，你和我，我们一生中大概要花大约
90,000 hours at work across our lifetime. That is about one third of our lives. If one third of your waking hours were spent in a place where you didn't feel welcome, you were constantly stressed, you were under intense pressure or scrutiny you were treated poorly, you are going to see that manifest in all other areas of your life. But at the same time, there is this expectation that you should be able to detach. If we just build up our lives enough beyond work, if we get a few hobbies, if we turn off our emails, you know, as soon as our shift ends or it hits five o'clock, we should be successfully able to turn off completely and like shape shift back into the normal version of ourselves. Most of us, though, know that is not true. We know that it's very hard to have that separation
9만个小时在工作上。这大约占我们生命的三分之一。如果你清醒时间的的三分之一都在一个让你感到不受欢迎、让你持续承受压力、承受巨大压力或审视、受到恶劣对待的地方度过，你就会看到这种状况在你生活的所有其他领域中显现出来。但与此同时，人们有一种期望，认为你应该能够抽离。如果我们能在工作之外建立足够丰富的生活，如果我们培养一些爱好，如果我们关掉电子邮件，你知道的，一旦换班结束或者到了五点钟，我们就应该能够成功地完全关闭，像变形一样变回正常的自己。然而，我们大多数人都知道事实并非如此。我们知道要做到这种分离是非常困难的，
because when you spend that much time in a job, a profession, an environment, it will ultimately influence your personality, your thoughts, your beliefs, even your sense of hope. And it also becomes kind of like a defining feature of how other people identify you as well. You know, what's the first question that you are inevitably going to be asked in a new social situation at basically every party, every social situation, every conference that you go to? What do you do for work? It is inescapable. This can create a psychological state that we know as enmeshment. So in meshment, this concept was originally used to describe codependency in families, and especially in families where there was a lack of boundaries. And it meant that there was kind of no way of separating, you know, a parent and a child or a sibling.
因为当你把那么多时间花在一项工作、一个职业、一个环境中时，它最终会影响你的性格、你的想法、你的信念，甚至你的希望感。而且它也开始成为其他人如何识别你的一个决定性特征。你知道，在每一个聚会、每一个社交场合、你参加的每一个会议中，在新的社交情境下，你不可避免会被问到的第一个问题是什么？你是做什么工作的？这是无法逃避的。这可能会产生一种心理状态，我们称之为“纠缠”（enmeshment）。这种概念最初被用来描述家庭中的共生依赖，特别是在缺乏边界的家庭中。这意味着父母与孩子或兄弟姐妹之间基本上无法分清彼此。
Everything was intertwined. They did everything together. They had all the same beliefs. They had the same routine and their lives were enmeshed. This can also happen with your job or with the workplace when a disproportionate amount of time is spent at work, is spent talking about work, is focused on your career, is spent with co-workers. There needs to be a natural separation of some sort. Otherwise, we do kind of end up tying everything back to our job and that's going to directly impact the their self-worth and our self-worth. It's important to remember that I think the current culture around work is very different to what it was a few years back. It is very hard to disconnect. Actually, in Australia, we just passed, like, right to disconnect laws, which basically
一切都交织在一起。他们一起做每一件事。他们拥有完全相同的信念。他们有着相同的作息，他们的生活纠缠在一起。这种情况也可能发生在你的工作或工作场所中，当不成比例的时间花在工作上、花在谈论工作上、专注于你的职业生涯、与同事在一起时。必须某种程度上保持自然的离。否则，我们确实最终会把所有事情都归结到我们的工作上，这会直接影响到他们的自我价值以及我们的自我价值。重要的一 Remember，我认为当前关于工作的文化与几年前非常不同。断联真的很难。实际上，在澳大利亚，我们刚刚通过了类似“断联权”的法律，这基本上
means that if you don't answer your boss's text at 7pm, they, like, can't fire you, they can't say anything about it, which is an amazing step forward. But a lot of us will still check our work emails after 7 p.m. on the weekends, because it's so much more. accessible and I think because I don't know I just feel like previously our career was just the thing that we did to make money now there's a lot more glory to it it's the thing that you can brag about it's this thing that identifies you it's this thing that others use to kind of place you in their life this is all basically a long way of saying that you know work is such a huge part of who you are and more so the further along you get into this decade it's a very common experience that
意味着如果你在晚上7点不回老板的信息，他们不能解雇你，也不能对此说什么，这是一个了不起的进步。但我们中的许多人仍然会在晚上7点以后或周末查看工作邮件，因为工作更容易触及了，而且我想，因为我不知道，我只是觉得以前我们的职业只是我们用来赚钱的事情，现在它有了更多的光彩，它是你可以吹嘘的事情，它是标榜你身份的事情，它是别人用来在生活中为你定位的事情。这基本上都在说明一件事：工作是你作为谁的巨大组成部分，随着你进入这个年代的深入，更是如此。这是一个非常普遍的经历：
as you age, the circles that represent friends, play, socializing, hobbies, free time, leisure, those circles get a lot smaller. And the circles representing work, responsibility, career, they get larger. And sorry, one more point on this as well. When you are in the early stages of your career, you want to do everything right and you want to be good and you want to be praised and you want to be promoted. You know, you're also probably the least experienced. You don't have as much knowledge. And that can again also lead to a real hustle culture mentality of like, you know, I have to be the one staying late. I have to be the one who never makes mistakes. I have to put up with whatever is thrown my way, including a toxic culture or a bad work environment. Because, you know,
随着年龄的增长，代表朋友、玩耍、社交、爱好、闲暇、休闲的圈子会变得越来越小。而代表工作、责任、职业的圈子则会变大。抱歉，关于这一点还有最后一点。当你处于职业生涯的早期阶段时，你希望把每件事都做好，你希望表现优秀，你希望得到表扬，你希望得到晋升。你知道，你可能也是经验最欠缺的。你没有那么多的知识。而这又会再次导致一种真正的“奋斗文化”心态，比如：“我必须是那个留到最晚的人。我必须是那个从不犯错的人。我必须忍受迎面而来的任何事情，包括有毒的文化或糟糕的工作环境。”因为，你知道的，
everyone has done it before me. This is just how it is. This is what is expected. I can't say anything. I cannot say anything because all jobs are like this. I just have to put up with it. And in those circumstances, you have to take very special care of your well-being. I want to kind of tell you a story of my worst job. I want to tell you a story of my most toxic workplace. So the worst job I've ever worked by far was back when I was at university in Canberra. And I worked at a restaurant and I'm not going home. I said the name. I'm not going to say the name. but it was a steak restaurant and it was very expensive so a lot of like CEOs and government people and people in town for work who wanted to like spend big on a meal would come to this restaurant
在我之前每个人都这么做过。事情就是这样。这就是大家的期望。我什么也不能说。我什么都不能说，因为所有工作都这样。我只能忍着。在这种情况下，你必须格外照顾好自己的身心健康。我想讲一个关于我最糟糕的工作的故事。我想讲一个关于我最toxic的工作场所的故事。到目前为止，我做过的最糟糕的工作是我在堪培拉上大学的时候。我曾在一家餐馆工作，我不会说出名字。我说过名字了，我不会说出名字。但那是一家牛排馆，非常昂贵，所以很多CEO、政府官员以及来城里工作、想在餐饮上挥霍大笔金钱的人都会来这家餐馆。
and it looked very lovely from the outside it looked very like designer luxury but behind the scenes it was just awful it was it was a walking HR disaster there were like three things that and made it really, really terrible. Firstly, there was a group of people, group of women who had worked there for like years, some of them for like five years, super clicky. And they were all like managers and supervisors and they were all friends. They would go on holiday together. They were honestly just horrific.
从外面看它非常可爱，看起来非常像设计师打造的奢华场所，但在幕后，它简直糟透了。它简直是一个行走的HR灾难。有大约三件事让它变得真的、真的非常糟糕。首先，有一群人，一群女性，在那里工作了多年，其中一些人甚至干了五年，超级抱团。她们都是经理和主管，而且都是朋友。她们会一起去度假。老实说，她们简直太可怕了。
So new people would start like myself and they would kind of almost, oh, they also lived together. I remember that being part of it. Some of them lived in the same house. and you would start and they would like vet you to just see if you were like one of them. And if even one of them didn't like you, they didn't think that you were like working hard enough or you weren't going to like pick up their shifts or do whatever they said, they would make your life awful.
所以像我这样刚去的新人，她们几乎会……哦，她们还住在一起。我记得这也是其中一部分。她们中的一些人住在同一个房子里。你刚开始上班时，她们会对你进行“政审”，看看你是不是和她们一路人。只要其中一个人不喜欢你，觉得你工作不够努力，或者不会帮她们顶班、不按她们说的做，她们就会让你的生活变得痛苦不堪。
I remember one time getting yelled at by one of the senior girls who worked there for coming into work and immediately making myself a glass of water because I used to ride my bike all the way from like uni and it would be really really hot in the summertime and I'd have to wear this black outfit and I'd ride my bike from uni to work and I would make myself a glass of water make myself a drink glass of water and she was like you are incredibly entitled you don't even have your apron on you haven't even like clocked in yet and it was just that kind of stuff like they wanted to make your life difficult and like during the busy period all the junior staff would be working and they would be like the back gossiping. So that was the first component was the click. Then there was the boss and I
我记得有一次，我被一个在那工作的资深女孩大吼大叫，因为我一进公司就马上给自己倒了一杯水，因为我骑自行车从大学一路骑过来，夏天天气非常非常热，我还得穿这套黑色的制服，我骑自行车从大学到工作地点，然后给自己倒了杯水、喝了一杯水，她就说：“你真有够自以为是的，你甚至连围裙都没系，你甚至都还没打卡呢。”就是这种事情——她们就是想让你的生活变得艰难，而且在忙碌的时段，所有的初级员工都在干活，而她们却在后面八卦。所以这是第一个部分，也就是那个小团体。然后就是老板，我
cannot even begin to tell you how much I dislike this man and the dread I would have when working with him alone. And he would like deliberately try and make you uncomfortable as a joke and like you'd be scheduled to finish at nine. But if you did just one small thing to annoy him, or you know, you wouldn't laugh at his joke. He'd make you stay until 11, just. with him. Just you and him in this like one restaurant and he would make you wipe down everything again and again and again and then make you go down in the elevator with him and make these like disgusting jokes whilst no one was like there. He was so gross. He was so gross. And he would yell at you. He would pretend to trip you and when we were closed he'd like bring all of his buddies
甚至无法开始向你表达我是多么讨厌这个家伙，以及当我独自和他一起工作时感到的那种恐惧。他会故意试图让你感到不舒服，当成笑话一样，比如你本该9点下班。但如果你做了一件哪怕很小的事惹恼了他，或者，你知道的，你不笑他的笑话。他会让你留到11点，就。跟他一起。只有你和他在这家餐厅里，他会让你一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地把所有的东西都擦拭干净，然后让你和他一起坐电梯，在空无一人的时候开这种恶心的玩笑。他太恶心了。他太恶心了。他会对你大吼大叫。他会假装绊倒你，当我们关门时，他会叫上他所有的狐朋狗友
to get drunk and you would have to stay on shift to like serve them free alcohol otherwise you would get fired. And you know, oh my God, sorry, I'm going on about this man, but he is a terrible man. And I remember for years afterwards, if I thought I would see him, I would like, I would be scared. You know, those people you just look at and like, there's nothing behind the eyes. That was it. And then finally, there were just the customers, you know, they were so rude. And I think that they definitely expected a lot from their experience because they were paying for the experience. But the kitchen was understaffed. We were often down three people because all the senior people would be in the break room and our bus was like never going to stand up for us and that time
来喝酒，而你必须留下来加班为他们端茶倒水、提供免费酒精，否则你就会被解雇。你知道的，天哪，对不起，我一直在抱怨这个男人，但他是个糟糕透顶的男人。我记得在这之后的几年里，如果我以为我会看到他，我都会……我会感到害怕。你知道那些你一看就会觉得“这个人眼里空洞无物”的人吗？就是那样。最后，还有那些顾客，你知道的，他们太粗鲁了。而且我认为他们确实对自己的体验抱有很高的期望，因为他们是付了钱来消费的。但厨房人手不足。我们经常少三个人，因为所有的资深员工都在休息室里，而我们的老板根本不会为我们挺身而出。那段时光
was so terrible for me because every night I would go to work and I would get paid not very much and I would just cry before I had to ride my bike over and I wanted to quit so badly and I would get anxious walking through the door. Everyone was so on edge so there wasn't even like a camaraderie or a friendship that could sustain you when it got bad. And I was like in my early 20s at the time. So it just felt like, you know, this is something I have to tolerate. I have to just take it because I'm trying to finish my degree. And, you know, I was just like getting sick, sick with worry about going to work.
对我来说太糟糕了，因为每天晚上我去上班，工资并不高，我骑自行车过去之前甚至会先哭一场。我太想辞职了，一走进大门我就会感到焦虑。每个人都处于极度紧绷的状态，所以当事情变糟时，甚至连能够支撑你度过难关的袍泽之情或友谊都没有。当时我二十岁出头。所以感觉就像是，你知道的，这是我必须容忍的事情。我必须忍受它，因为我正在努力完成我的学位。而且，你知道的，我简直急出了病，担心去上班急得生病，
And thinking that this was like everything to me, this job. Like I'd be thinking about like something, some mistake I did and how I could fix that like the next day and like all these things. and it just took such a significant toll. And in hindsight, you know, I still have nightmares. I, oh my God, I'm remembering this. I had a nightmare last night about this colleague who I worked with. And that was like, how many years ago? Seven, six, seven years ago.
并且认为这对我来说就是全部，这份工作。比如我会想着某事，某个我犯的错误，以及第二天我该如何解决它，还有所有这些事情。它真的带来了如此沉重的代价。回想起来，你知道的，我仍然会做噩梦。天哪，我想起来了。我昨夜还梦到了一个曾和我共事的同事。那是多少年前的事了？七年，六、七年前。
And she was like following me around my house. Like that was literally a dream I had about her last night. And I was so scared, like not outside the dream, but back at the job to quit. And on my last shift, I called in. sick actually, which I think it was like one of three times I have ever done that. And then I blocked all of their numbers and all of their Facebook profiles because that was how they used to like talk to us back then. And I just was like, I'm never going to, I don't want to interact with you ever again. And I know that I am not the only one who has had this experience. This is just one example,
她就像那样在我的房子周围跟踪我。这字面意思就是我昨晚梦到她的场景。我是如此害怕，不是在梦外，而是回到那个工作岗位上去辞职。而在我的最后一次班次上，我实际上请了病假，我想这大概是我这辈子总共三次这么做中的一次。然后我拉黑了他们所有人的电话号码和所有的Facebook主页，因为那是他们当年和我们交流的方式。我当时就想：我再也不要，我再也不想和你们有任何交集了。我知道我不是唯一一个有过这种经历的人。这只是一个例子，
a hospitality example, right? And I think my experience, the toxicity came from the piece. people. There was this level of harassment and bullying and intimidation that takes an emotional toll, specifically because it has to do with an underlying sense of security and I would even say safety when I was there. And the uncertainty that each shift would, you know, bring something new and not in a fun way, but in like a destructive, anxiety-inducing way. I don't think anyone who worked at this restaurant at the time was like having a good time. And interestingly, I actually read a study the other day that was conducted in China back in 2021. And what the study said was that when a workplace in general, when the culture is toxic, the feeling becomes toxic amongst
一个酒店业的例子，对吧？我认为我的经历中，有毒的成分来自人。这种程度的骚扰、霸凌和恐吓会带来情感上的代价，特别是当它与一种潜在的安全感有关时，甚至可以说是当我在那里的安全感有关时。并且每一次上班都会带来新的不确定性，而且不是以一种有趣的方式，而是以一种具有破坏性的、引发焦虑的方式。我认为当时在这家餐厅工作的任何人都没有觉得好过。有趣的是，我最近读到了一项2021年在中国进行的研究。该研究表明，当整个工作场所、当这种文化有毒时，这种感觉就会在同事之间变得有毒。这意味着他们更有可能排外、霸凌、表现得相当残酷，因为他们自己觉得对生活的控制力太少，而且非常不满。
the co-workers. And it means that they are more likely to ostracize, bully, be quite cruel, because they themselves feel like they have so little control and they are so dissatisfied. That is often the root of workplace bullying and workplace intimidation and just meanness and cruelty is that these individuals recognize that they're actually not happy themselves, but there's this like sadistic need to see that unhappiness reflected back in someone else. And this can extend all the way from the top. And I mean like your bosses, you know, they start to feel this shift as well and they start to act in a way that's just like very unkind. And you don't feel respected.
这通常是职场霸凌、职场恐吓以及刻薄和残忍的根源：这些个体意识到他们自己其实并不快乐，但有一种带萨德主义倾向的需求，想要在别人身上看到那种不快乐的倒影。这种情况可以一直延伸到高层。我是指你的老板，你知道的，他们也开始感受到这种转变，他们开始表现得非常不友好。你不会觉得自己受到尊重。
You don't feel like you can speak up. You feel completely stuck. This really links back to me towards a theme or a lack of respect. And that also extends to other kinds of workplaces, you know, not just hospitality jobs, but corporate jobs where people don't respect. your boundaries, they ask you to work when, when you know you can't. They assign you things that you just don't have the skills or the capacity to do, and then they criticize you, they make you feel small. That is a very hard thing to go through and still maintain your sense of self-esteem.
你不会觉得你可以畅所欲言。你感到完全陷入了困境。这确实让我联想到一个主题，那就是缺乏尊重。而这也延伸到了其他类型的工作场所，不仅是酒店业工作，还有那些人们不尊重你的边界的企业工作，他们要求你在你知道自己无法胜任的时候工作。他们分配给你一些你根本不具备技能或能力去完成的任务，然后他们批评你，让你觉得自己很渺小。要经历这些还要保持自尊心，是一件非常困难的事。
You know, I've heard from a lot of people whose biggest complaint about their toxic workplace has been the unreasonable workload and the expectations that made them feel like they were on a constant treadmill and this treadmill was getting faster and faster. And I would categorize a boss that does this as using fear-based leadership, pushing people to their limits out of a fear of repercussion, you know, getting fired, being humiliated, being criticized, rather than giving people space to expand. It's all about consequences rather than growth. That treadmill I'm speaking about that puts us into a hyper aroused and stressed elevated state because you are essentially running on cortisol and adrenaline. If you've ever wondered why after you go through a super stressful busy period
你知道的，我听很多人抱怨过，他们对有毒工作场所最大的抱怨是不合理的工作量和期望，这让他们感觉自己就像在一部永无止境的跑步机上，而这部跑步机越跑越快。我会把这样做的老板归类为使用“恐惧驱动型领导力”：出于对后果（被解雇、被羞辱、被批评）的恐惧，把员工逼到极限，而不是给员工成长的空间。这一切都是关于后果，而不是关于成长。我所说的那个跑步机，把我们带入了一种过度觉醒、充满压力的高亢状态，因为你本质上是在靠皮质醇和肾上腺素硬撑。如果你曾好奇为什么在经历了一个超级压力大、忙碌的时期后，
at work or at school, you immediately get sick, that is why your body requires mental and of course physical rest to switch off, to restore, to pleaded reserves, and more importantly to calm down that stress response because that stress response is incredibly harsh on our bodies. When we aren't given that chance, it weakens our immune system. It makes us worse at fighting illnesses or more susceptible to certain diseases, certain sicknesses. So it's not just that this is having a mental consequence. You are going to also see a physical result of this bad environment. Then there is overworking as well, which feels very similar to the above, right? This culture of like, You need to give this company everything.
在工作或学校之后，你会立刻生病，原因就在这里：你的身体需要精神上的、当然还有身体上的休息来关闭、恢复、补充枯竭的储备，更重要的是，要平息那种应激反应，因为这种应激反应对我们的身体极其残酷。当我们没有得到这个机会时，它就会削弱我们的免疫系统。它使我们对抗疾病的能力变差，或者更容易感染某些疾病、某些病痛。所以这不仅仅是产生心理上的后果。你还会看到这种糟糕环境带来的生理结果。然后还有过度工作，这感觉和上面非常相似，对吧？那种文化，比如：你需要为这家公司付出一切。
You need to be on 100% of the time. There tends to be a belief that overworking and to an extent burnout is an occupational hazard of some jobs. The same way that you know, you're more likely to be injured working in a mine or doing something dangerous like working on an oil rig and you accept that that is part of the role. if you're a doctor, a lawyer, a nurse, overtime and burnout, just, you know, you just have to accept that. But that is also becoming the norm for almost all jobs these days. And I'm not talking about staying 30 minutes to finish off your emails, but late nights, working weekends without being compensated without getting support. The biggest contributor to burnout, according to the University of California, Berkeley, the biggest number one thing is overworking. an excessive workload.
你需要100%的时间保持在线。人们往往有一种信念，即过度工作并在某种程度上职业倦怠是某些工作的职业危害。就像你在矿井工作或做一些危险的事情（比如在石油钻井平台上工作）更有可能受伤一样，你接受这是角色的一部分。如果你是一名医生、律师、护士，加班和倦怠，你知道的，你只能接受。但这在如今几乎成为所有工作的常态。我不是指留下来30分钟把电子邮件发完，而是指深夜加班、周末工作，却没有得到补偿，也没有得到支持。根据加州大学伯克利分校的说法，导致职业倦怠的最大因素，排名第一的事情就是过度工作。过重的工作量。
And they have even made the claim, which I think we should take with a grain of salt, but the University of California probably knows more than me. They've made the claim that burnout is contributing to the deaths of millions of people each year because of its all-round negative impact on your health. You know, I want to say this not to scare you, but to remind you that you are not being dramatic. if you find yourself completely depleted by the expectation to work long hours and the inability
他们甚至断言（我认为我们对此应该持保留态度，但加州大学懂得可能比我多），他们断言，由于职业倦怠对健康的全面负面影响，它每年导致数百万人死亡。你知道，我说这话不是为了吓唬你，而是为了提醒你：如果你发现自己被长时间工作的期望彻底榨干，并且因为你是初级员工、因为一直以来都是这样而无法说不，你绝不是在无理取闹。我将稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想谈谈这对于我们健康的各个方面所带来的进一步后果。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将拆解精神韧性、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
to say no because you are a junior because this is how it's always been done. I'm going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to talk about some of the further consequences of that for all elements of our health. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字叫作T-W-O-Persent。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的世纪骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想怎么会发生这种事。警察
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her. friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought how could this happen to me? The cops
似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友s》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。
didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么。并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克毒品。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down. and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
需要说明的是，1984年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了，所以。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我们太沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你认为在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我希望你真的能成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。无论是过重的工作量、霸凌、恐吓、微观管理、沟通不畅、糟糕的文化，各种形式的有毒工作场所都会留下它们的印记。而且你甚至不需要在那里待很长时间就会如此。根据美国心理学会的说法，当我们遇到这些环境时，它会导致员工（也就是你和我）变得，
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. Whether it's excessive workload, bullying, intimidation, micromanagement, poor communication, bad culture, all forms of toxic workplaces leave their mark. And you don't even have to have been there for a long time for that to be the case. According to the American Psychological Association, when we encounter these environments, it can lead employees, that means you and I, to become,
用他们的话说，“生病、害怕并寻找辞职的方法”。他们还持续报告称，在与他们交谈的人中，大约有65%的人的心理健康在这段时期有所下降。有毒的工作场所夺走了我们的兴奋感、我们的能量、我们做好事的意愿和渴望，并把它们变成了恐惧。它们把它们变成了恐惧，因为我们需要钱，我们需要工作来生存。所以当工作不顺时，我们生活的其他每一个元素都会受到威胁。你知道的，我们已经讨论过职业倦怠带来的代价。但职业倦怠不仅仅是一种感觉。
and this is their words, sick, scared, and to look for ways to quit. They also consistently report about 65% of the people they spoke to that their mental well-being declines during these periods. toxic workplaces take excitement, they take our energy, they take our willingness and our desire to do well, and they turn it into fear. And they turn it into fear because we need money and we need a job to survive. So when that is not going well, every other element of our lives feels threatened. You know, we've already spoken about that cost when it comes to burnout. But burnout is more than just one feeling.
它实际上分12个阶段发展。因此，职业倦怠（burnout）这个术语是由心理学家赫伯特·弗罗伊登伯格创造、发现、发起、无论你怎么说。在他当年的最初理论中，他提出我们往往甚至在到达最后几个阶段之前都没有注意到职业倦怠。也就是第10、11和12阶段。这个时候我们才真正感觉到它。我们生病了。我们一直很累。我们感到困惑，无法调节我们的焦虑。
It actually develops in 12 stages. So the term burnout was created, discovered, I don't know, initiated, whatever you want to say, by the psychologist Herbert Freudenberg. And in his initial theory back in the day, he suggests that we often don't even notice burnout until we get to the final few stages. So stage 10, 11, and 12. And this is the time when we really feel it. We are sick. We are tired all the time. we are confused, unable to regulate our anxiety.
我们正在走向一条下行的螺旋。但它实际上开始得要早得多，它从那些我们视为积极的事情开始，对吧？过度的野心，试图满足期望或融入环境。这就像一段有毒的恋爱关系，我们认为自己错了，并通过更努力地工作来试图修复自己，结果最终意识到，你知道的，其实从来都不是我的问题。一直都是对方的问题。
It's a downward spiral that we're heading. But it actually begins a lot earlier and it begins with things that we would see as positive, right? Excessive ambition, trying to meet the expectations or fit into the environment. It's like a toxic relationship where we think we are in the wrong and we try to fix ourselves by working harder only to eventually realize, you know, it was actually never me. It was always this other party.
职业倦怠的早期阶段还包括试图在盘子里塞更多东西，忽视基本需求或琐事，只是说：“我太忙了，没空理那个”，觉得一天的时间不够用，疏远朋友，发现生活中的其他领域也存在冲突，比如与伴侣、室友、朋友，然后空虚感就来了。也许只有当我们处于这种最后的状态，回顾过去几周，回顾过去几个月，然后思考，
The early stages of burnout also include trying to put more on your plate, neglecting basic needs or chores, just saying, I'm too busy for that, feeling like you don't have enough time in your day, withdrawing from friends, finding that there is conflict in other areas of your life as well, with your partner, with your roommates, with your friends, and then the emptiness sets in. And it may only be when we are in this final state, and we're looking back at the last few weeks, we're looking back at the last months, and we think,
职业倦怠的早期阶段还包括试图承担更多的工作、忽视基本需求或琐事、嘴里只说着“我太忙了没空管那个”、感觉一天的时间不够用、开始疏远朋友、发现生活中的其他领域也出现了冲突（比如与伴侣、室友、朋友之间），接着空虚感便会袭来。也许只有当我们处于这种最后的状态，回顾过去几周、过去几个月，然后我们才会想：
oh, oh my goodness, this has been coming for a long time. You know, hindsight is often the first time that we notice this pattern. And this is what can lead us to the dark path of chronic burnout or a burnout cycle. So if you are someone who finds that they get burnt out, like every three to four months, maybe, like clockwork. But, you know, then you feel a little bit better a couple weeks in. So you put everything back on your plate and you try to adapt and then, you know, you feel burnt out again. You're not going through different cycles, different like stages of burnout because you're actually not even recovering. You've probably never even escaped the burnout to begin with.
哦，哦天哪，这种情况已经持续很久了。你知道，事后诸葛亮往往是我们第一次注意到这种模式的时候。而这正是把我们引向慢性职业倦怠或倦怠循环这条黑暗道路的原因。所以，如果你发现自己每隔三到四个月就会精疲力竭一次，也许就像时钟一样规律。但是，你知道，两周后你又会感觉好一点。于是你把所有事情重新揽回自己身上，试图去适应，然后，你知道的，你又会感到精疲力竭。你其实并没有经历不同的循环、不同的倦怠阶段，因为你实际上根本没有恢复。你可能从一开始就根本没有摆脱过倦怠。
You've just gone back to an earlier stage. You are in the burnout cycle. And that cycle involves momentary recovery met by escalation. People in overwhelming or toxic workplaces are more likely to report this kind of experience and sometimes it can last years. Toxic workplaces can even at times create PTSD or lasting trauma after you have left that environment. A friend of my dads actually had such a traumatic experience at a job. He was, you know, it was like 10 years ago. And he has never been able to recover from that. On a smaller scale, I had a friend who just recently got out of this terrible job,
你只是回到了较早的阶段。你正处于倦怠循环中。而这个循环包含短暂的恢复，随即又是恶化。身处压抑或有毒工作场所的人更有可能报告这种经历，有时这甚至会持续数年。有毒的工作场所甚至有时会在你离开那个环境后导致创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或持久的创伤。我爸爸的一个朋友在工作中确实有过这样痛苦的经历。那是，你知道的，大约10年前的事了。他至今未能从中恢复。在一个较小的范围内，我有个朋友最近刚脱离了一份糟糕的工作，
maybe like six months ago. And oh my goodness, I just hated her boss. Never met her boss. Hated him. He would single her out. He had such, he was just mean. He just obviously did not like her for whatever. ever reason and he made it very known. And then one day he just made her redundant out of the blue.
大概是六个月前吧。哦天哪，我太讨厌她的老板了。虽然我从未见过她老板。但我就是讨厌他。他会针对她。他太……他就是很刻薄。显然不知出于什么原因，他就是不喜欢她，而且他毫不掩饰这一点。然后有一天，他毫无预兆地直接把她裁掉了。
After that, of course, you know, it really echoes that story we said before. She had to find a new job. And it was so interesting yet quite sad to watch her, you know, apply for jobs and to watch her just struggle and struggle and feel like she wasn't qualified, she wasn't confident enough because her expectations for herself had sunk to his level and left a mark on her self-worth. And, you know, the more we care about someone's opinion because they are in a position of authority or we rely on their good opinion for our future, the more weight we put on it, the more a negative opinion can really scar us. And it didn't matter what we said, her friends said, you know, didn't matter that we thought she was talented, skillful, charismatic, her inner critic had taken
在那之后，当然，你知道的，这真的呼应了我们之前说过的那个故事。她不得不去找新工作。看着她申请工作，看着她不断挣扎、痛苦，觉得自己不够资格、不够自信，这种情景既有趣又让人感到相当悲哀，因为她对自己的期望已经降到了他的水平，并在她的自我价值感上留下了印记。而且，你知道的，我们越是在意某个人的意见——因为他们处于权威地位，或者我们的未来要依靠他们对我们的好评——我们赋予它的分量就越重，负面评价对我们的伤害也就越深。不管我们说什，不管她的朋友们怎么说——无论我们觉得她多么有才华、有能力、有魅力——她的内心批判者还是把她老板的话用她自己的声音复述给她听。
her boss's words and spoken them back to her in her own voice. So what do we do to heal from these situations? You know, unless you were suddenly a millionaire, which congratulations, please let me know if that's the case, congrats. But unless that is your case, you know, we need to work. You can't always just quit a secure job even if you want to, even if you're really struggling. That's why toxic workplaces have their own place in hell. I also think that, you know, having a job is also an important part of our purpose, our identity. So you want to have a positive environment that you can thrive in, that you can achieve your goals in. So what do we do to kind of cope in a situation where that's not the case and how do we cope afterwards? One of the best
那么，面对这些情况，我们该如何疗愈呢？你知道的，除非你突然变成百万富翁——如果是这样的话，恭喜你，请告诉我一声，恭喜恭喜。但除非你是这种情况，否则，你知道的，我们必须工作。你不能总是说辞职就辞职，哪怕你很想这么做，哪怕你真的举步维艰。这就是为什么有毒的工作场所就像人间炼狱一样。我也认为，你知道的，拥有一份工作也是我们的人生目标和身份认同的重要组成部分。所以你会希望有一个能让你蓬勃发展、实现目标的积极环境。那么，在情况并非如此的时候，我们该如何应对？事后又该如何调整？我的一位朋友对我说过的话中，
things that a friend of mine has ever said to me, ever, is if someone, someone, you know, treats you badly, they are not going to treat you any better, the harder you work. And that left me gobsmacked. Because I think about my toxic jobs, I only spoke about one, but there have been others. And I think about them and I think about how the whole time I was the one pushing myself to fit in. I was working so hard thinking that I was the problem when actually it was the environment that was the common denominator amongst not just my experience, but many others. In many ways, and I've said it before, but a toxic workplace and a toxic relationship, like share a lot of traits, they make you doubt your own self-worth, they make you feel like you are the
有史以来最好、最棒的一句就是：如果有人——某个你知道的人——对你不好，你工作再努力，他们也不会对你好一点。这让我当场惊呆了。因为我想起我那些有毒的工作，我只说了一份，但还有其他的。我想起那些经历，想起我一直在逼自己去融入。我拼命工作，以为问题出在自己身上，而实际上，环境才是不仅在我身上、而且在许多其他人身上都存在的共同点。在许多方面——我以前也说过——有毒的工作场所和有毒的关系有很多共同点，它们会让你怀疑自己的自我价值，让你觉得问题出在你身上，让你觉得很难离开，它们责怪你、打击你、你知道的——当然它们也有不同之处，但我觉得当你这样看待它时，你就会开始意识到，你值得拥有更多。在某种程度上，你的工作其实和你选择的亲密关系一样重要，就像你理应从伴侣和朋友那里得到最好的一切一样。你理应从工作场所得到最好的一切。
problem, they make it hard to leave, they blame you, they tear you down, they, you know, they are of course different as well, but I think when you consider it in this way, you begin to realize that you deserve more. Your job is actually just as important in some ways as the relationship that you choose and the same way that you deserve the absolute best from a partner from a friend. You deserve the absolute best from a workplace. I think with toxic jobs, this is not a matter of trying to convince someone to be nicer to fix their attitude problem for you. It's not a matter of trying to convince a workplace to overhaul their culture, it is a situation where, you know, they've probably been asked before and they wouldn't do it. You are not the first person to suffer and not the first person with these
我认为对于有毒的工作，这不是去试图说服别人对你更友好、让他们为你修正态度问题的问题。这也不是试图说服一个工作场所彻底改革其企业文化的问题，这是一种这样的情况：你知道的，他们以前可能已经被要求过很多次了，但他们就是不肯改。你不是第一个受苦的人，也不是第一个遇到这些问题的人。所以，当身处其中时，你的主要目标是——我知道这听起来可能有点自私——但它确实是严肃地熬过去。咬紧牙关熬过去，因为你无法独自承载一个混乱且有毒的环境所带来的负担。我的第一个大建议是，掌控你能掌控的事，并在工作之外寻找价值。把寻找乐趣、做自己喜欢的事、把快乐和激情重新注入那些不在工作场所的时间，当作一项使命。当我们经历这种经历时，确实有一种倾向，那就是回到家只想——首先你已经精疲力竭了，你已经情绪倦怠了。
problems. So whilst you are in it, your main goal is to, and I know it might sound quite selfish, but it's to seriously just get through it. Put your head down and get through it because you cannot bear the burden of a disorganized and toxic environment. My first big tip is, is to take control of what you can and find value outside of work. Make it a mission to have fun, to do things you enjoy, to put joy and excitement back into the hours that you're not in the workplace. There is definitely an inclination when we're going through this experience to come home and just be, first of you're exhausted, you're emotionally burnt out.
而对此的反应显然就是休息。就是躺着不动，就像进入植物人状态一样。我理解那种感觉，也理解那种冲动。我希望你把这当作第一选择，然后再去探索第二选择。而第二选择则是带着一种近乎反叛的心态说：我绝不让这该死的工作毁了我的生活。我绝不让这该死的工作剥夺我去体验美好、刺激、乐趣、激情以及除此之外一切美好感受的权利。
And obviously the reaction to that is just to rest. and is to lie still and is to just like enter a catatonic state. I get that feeling and I get that urge. I want you to treat that as the first option and then to explore the second option. And the second option is to almost in defiance say, I'm not going to let this shitty job ruin my life. I'm not going to let this shitty job mean that I cannot experience great beauty and excitement and fun and passion and all the best feelings beyond this is.
环境。所以，你无法控制老板如何对待你。你无法控制工作场所如何评估你的价值，但你可以控制，你知道的，你在睡觉前做什么。你可以控制上班前的那些时间：你可以开车去海滩，去看日出，去喝咖啡，和朋友一起喝早咖啡，下班后去看电影，而不是仅仅，你知道的，回到家瘫坐在沙发上。用生活填满那些你能掌控的时间。我还要强烈建议你，通过做一件我们称之为“按薪水办事”的事，来限制你对工作的感情投入。
environment. So you cannot control how a boss treats you. You cannot control how a workplace values you, but you can control, you know, what you do before you go to bed. You can control the hours before you go to work where you drive to the beach, you watch the sunrise, you get coffee, early morning coffee with a friend, you go to the movies after work instead of just, you know, coming home and sitting back on the couch. Fill those hours that you can control with the life. I also would really suggest to limit your emotional investment in your job by doing something that we call acting your wage.
显然，这是一个双关语，学着成熟一点（act your age），按薪水干活（act your wage）。你知道的，如果有人——在你能做到的范围内——如果有人没有为你的额外付出付钱给你，他们不感激你的额外付出。那就别去做。千万别做。你可能会觉得这与直觉相悖。你可能会想：不，我想在职业生涯中取得成就。我理解这一点。
Obviously, it's a play on words, act your age, act your wage. You know, if someone is as much as you can, if someone is not paying you for the extra effort, they're not appreciating you for the extra effort. Don't do it. Do not do it. You might think that this is counterintuitive. You might be like, no, I want to get ahead in my career. I understand that.
但这真的是一个让你的努力得到最多认可的地方吗？或者，你可以把那些试图给糟糕的老板留下好印象、试图给糟糕的同事留下好印象所花费的精力和时间，用在别处呢？比如多留出一个小时来申请新工作。多留出一个小时来进行自我关爱。多留出一个小时给朋友打电话，或者给妈妈打电话。而不是觉得你的生活就只有这份工作。当你身处其中时，很难做到抽离，
But is this the place in which your effort is going to be most recognized? Or could you take that effort and that time that you're spent trying to impress your terrible boss trying to impress your terrible co-workers? And could you put it towards having an extra hour to apply for new jobs? Having an extra hour to practice self-care. Having an extra hour to call a friend or to call your mom. instead of feeling like your life is just this job. It's hard to detach when you're in it,
但我希望你真正记住的是，你的工作其实并没有那么在意你。组织内部或工作场所里的某些人可能会关心你，但作为一个整体，它是一家公司，是一个组织，它的使命与你无关。我知道这听起来很悲观，但如果你明天离职了，他们也会找到替代者。所以不要把这当成一个大家庭。不要把它当作一种无私的友谊，任由他们用内疚感绑架你留下来。这只是一份工作。你有权按你的薪水干活。哦天哪，请在可以的时候请病假吧！这是我非常、非常、非常希望自己在全职做公司工作时做过的事情。自我离职时，
but I want you to really be reminded that your job does not care about you all that much. There are certain people within an organization or within your workplace that might care about you, but as a whole, it's a company, it's an organization, it's something that has a mission that isn't to do with you. And I know it sounds quite pessimistic, but if you were to leave tomorrow, they would find a replacement. And so do not treat this like a family. Do not treat it like it's this giving friendship and let them guilt you into staying. This is a job. You are entitled to act your wage. And oh my goodness, please take a sick day when you can. This was something that I wish, wish wish I had done when I was working full-time at my corporate job. I had so much sick leave by the
我积攒了那么多的病假。你必须记住，病假——你为那些日子付出了劳动，对吧？那是他们没有付给你、而是留给他们自己的钱。如果你离职了——也许这只在澳大利亚是这样——但如果你离职了，他们可以保留从你的工资中扣除的、本该留给你请病假用的钱。所以请务必请病假。这只是一份工作。我向你保证，10年后或者当你辞职后，你最大的遗憾之一一定会是：天哪，我真希望当时在我需要的时候请了心理健康假。
time I left. And you've got to remember that sick leave, you have been, that you've paid for those days, right? That is money that they have not paid you, which they have kept for themselves. And if you leave, and maybe this is just in Australia, but if you leave, like they get to keep the money that they have deducted from your paycheck for the days that you need to call in sick. So please take a sick day. This is just a job. I promise you that in 10 years time or after you quit, one of the big things, one of my big regrets is, oh my God, I wish I'd actually taken a mental health day when I needed it.
我真希望当时能好好照顾自己的情绪。我也认为，如果你处于一个独特的环境中，那里的主要问题是批评、主要问题是被压制、不被欣赏、没有受到祝贺，或者感到相当无聊、没有受到挑战，那就试着给自己一些自我肯定。所以，你知道的，自我强化是我学过的最有价值的心理工具之一。自我赞赏，你知道的，真正地恭喜自己、庆祝自己，尤其是当你身处一个这样的环境时，你会觉得：
I wish that I had taken care of my emotions. I also think that if you are in a unique environment in which the main problem is criticism, the main problem is being shut down, not being appreciated, it's not being congratulated or being quite bored, not feeling challenged. try and provide some self-congratulation. So, you know, self-reinforcement is one of the most valuable psychological tools. I've ever learnt self-approval, you know, actually congratulating yourself, celebrating yourself, especially when you're an environment where you're like,
我觉得这些人是不会为我这么做的。我们之所以被负面工作环境压得喘不过气来，其中一个非常重要的原因，就是我们开始期望我们的认可需要来自雇主，因为我们的职业是我们身份的核心支柱。除了工作场所之外，我们真的不知道去哪里寻找认可。在这里我要作一个说明。这种情况在你是一个高度成就导向的人时尤为明显。你过去非常，你知道的，是个好学生。
I don't think that these people are going to do that for me. Some of the reasons that, one of the big reasons that we become quite burdened by a negative work environment is we begin to expect that our validation, needs to come from our employer because our career is a core pillar of our identity. And we don't really know where to search without validation beyond the workplace. And I'm going to make a caveat here. This is especially the case of you are quite a high achiever. You were very, you know, a good student.
你是个尖子生。你，你知道的，就是一直很优秀。你是个天赋异禀的孩子。你习惯了表扬。你喜欢表扬。你喜欢被人祝贺。而当你得不到这些时，你会觉得自己一文不值。所以试着养成这样一种习惯：我真的为自己今天完成了所有这些工作感到骄傲。
You were an A student. You were, you know, just excelling. You're a gifted child. You were used to praise. You like praise. You like to be congratulated. And when you don't have that, it feels like you're quite. worthless. So try and get into the habit of being like, I'm really proud that I got all of that
我真的为自己尽了最大努力感到骄傲。我为自己在这件事上为自己所付出的额外努力感到骄傲。我为自己的工作感到骄傲。如果你知道自己做好了工作，就不需要依赖别人来告诉你你做得很好。现在，这最后一个建议实际上来自于我的一位朋友，就是我之前提到的几个月前被裁员的那位。当她身处那份糟糕透顶的工作中时，
done today. I'm really proud that I tried really hard. I'm really proud of the extra effort that I put in to this thing for me. I'm really proud of my work. You don't need to be reliant on someone else to tell you that you've done a good job if you know you've done a good job. Now, this final tip actually came from my friend who I was speaking about who was made redundant a few months back. And while she was in that terrible, terrible job. She said the one really amazing thing that worked for her was having an exit strategy. So the exit strategy is basically a timeline that you have for when you want to quit. It's quite unreasonable to be in a toxic workplace for a lot of us and to be like,
她说对她真正起作用的一件非常了不起的事情，就是制定退出策略。所以退出策略基本上就是为你想要辞职的时间设定一个时间线。对于我们许多人来说，身处有毒的工作环境中却说“我明天就要辞职”，这是非常不切实际的，因为我们需要钱来生存。而我认为，正是这种对我们所厌恶的事物的某种依赖感，导致我们感到如此受困。我们依赖这个糟糕的老板，依赖这份糟糕的工作，你需要开始展望未来并制定离开的时间线。所以离开的时间线不仅仅是找到新工作的即时目标，它是一种结构化的思考方式，思考你将如何达到那个目标以及如何将其分解。如果你听过我们关于“20多岁重塑自我的五种方法”那一集，你就会听到这个策略。方法就是把你的目标——
I'm just going to quit tomorrow because we need money to survive. And that's, I think, what contributes to us feeling quite trapped is a sense of almost dependency on this thing that we hate. we're dependent on this terrible boss, this terrible job, you need to start looking to the future and creating that timeline for leaving. So a timeline for leaving is not just like an immediate goal of getting a new job, it's a structured way of thinking about how you're going to get there and how you break it down. If you've listened to our episode on Five Ways to Reinvent yourself in your 20s, you'll have heard this strategy. The way to do it is to break your goals down,
你的离开目标——分解为一天、一周、一个月、六个月的目标。所以六个月的目标是离开那里。但一个月的目标是安排好几次工作面试。一周的目标是每周申请五份不同的工作。一天的目标是填写你的简历，思考谁可以作为你的推荐人，花五分钟浏览工作并将其加入书签以便以后查看。你需要有一种感觉，即：好吧，曙光就在前方。我要积极地开始努力离开这个工作场所，你会发现突然之间抽离变得容易多了。
your goal being to leave into one day, one week, one month, six month goals. So the six month goal is to be out of there. But the one month goal is to have a few job interviews lined up. The one week goal is to apply for five different jobs a week. And the one day goal is to be filling out your resume, to be thinking about who could be your references, to be taking five minutes to just search through jobs and bookmarking them for later. You need to have a sense of, okay, there is an end inside. I'm going to actively start working towards leaving this workplace, and you'll find that suddenly it becomes a lot easier to detach.
你可以开始不那么在乎了。抱歉爆粗口，但说真的，就是当你开始觉得——这其实只是一份工作，因为我能看到外面还有什么更好的选择，而且你不再被束缚在这种与更好选择无缘的有毒关系中。好了，我们要进行另一个短小的休息。但当我们回来时，我想谈谈你可以在事后采取的策略。即使在我们离开了一个有毒的、可怕的、糟糕的环境之后，那种情感影响有时仍然会挥之不去。所以接下来我们将讨论如何从中疗愈，以及更多精彩内容，
You can start to give less fucks. Sorry to swear, but seriously, it's when you start to just be like, this actually is a job because I can see what else is out there and you're not in this toxic relationship lined to what is better. All right, we're going to take another. short break. But when we come back, I want to talk about the strategies that you can use in the aftermath. Even after we leave a toxic, awful, terrible environment, sometimes the emotional impact lingers. So we're going to talk about how to heal from that and much, much more after
就在这段短暂的休息之后。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？我们搞错了。我们在世界上对之惊恐不安的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在经历这一切后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是Apple Podcasts、iHeart Radio应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Percent”。任何男性都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you, will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定亲自动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友们》。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代可卡因的节目。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
是的，对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难中学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
Yeah, for me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch.
生活变成了关于赢与输的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难中学习》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和人生目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索《艰难中学习》，立即收听。从任何可能给你带来创伤、情感动荡、情感冲突的情况中恢复过来，真正需要的是找到释怀。作为人类，我们喜欢事情有一个整洁的故事书般的结局。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Recovering from any situation that has perhaps brought you trauma, emotional turmoil, emotional conflict really involves finding closure. As humans, we like things to have a neat storybook ending.
我们喜欢能够把一段记忆收好，然后说：这说得通。我不得不经历这一切是说得通的。那件事发生的原因是说得通的。我现在可以从那件事中走出来了。当我们经历那些极度超出我们控制、相当动荡且痛苦的事情时，很难找到那个结论。也很难找到一种意义感，通常是因为根本没有任何意义。你不得不经历一个有毒的工作场所，这背后没有任何意义。这只是一种不必要的创伤。所以，相反，你需要为自己找到那种释怀。你不可能去找你那糟糕的老板或糟糕的同事说：你为什么要那样对待我？你为什么对我那么残酷？你不能去找
We like to be able to put a memory away and say, that makes sense. That makes sense that I had to go through that. That makes sense as to why that happened. And I can move on from that now. When we go through things that are very much out of our control or quite turbulent and hurtful, it's very hard to find that conclusion. It's very hard to also find a sense of meaning, often because there isn't any. There is no meaning behind you having to experience a toxic workplace. Like it's just an unnecessary trauma. So, in Instead, you need to find that closure for yourself. You can't necessarily go to your bad boss or your bad colleague and say, why did you treat me that way? Why were you so cruel to me? You can't go and talk to
你们公司的CEO说：你为什么付给我这么少？你为什么忽视我的需求？相反，你需要为自己找到那种认知上的释怀，它能让你从已经结束的事情过渡到新的事物。最简单的方法就是承认影响，就是承认：是的，我确实经历了那件事，那真的、真的很困难。即使这是一种被剥夺权利的创伤——也就是说，其他人并不理解的创伤——即使它不在人们认为严重的清单上，但对我来说它就是很严重，它影响了我。而且它真的很难熬。我有权为自己感到难过。我有权为此感到悲伤。然后我需要继续前这里重要的另一件事是，有时当我们
the CEO of your company and say, why did you pay me so little? Why did you disregard my needs? Instead, you need to find that cognitive closure for yourself that's going to allow you to transition away from what's finished to something new. The easiest way to do that is to acknowledge the impact is to acknowledge, yeah, I did go through that and that was really, really difficult. And even if this is a disenfranchised trauma, so kind of a trauma that other people don't understand, even if it's, you know, not on people's list of what's serious to me it was and it impacted me. And it was really hard. And I'm allowed to feel sorry for myself. I'm allowed to feel sad about it. And then I need to move on. Another thing that's important here is sometimes when we
处于那种环境中时。我们几乎被心理操控（gaslighting）得觉得那是正常的。我们被心理操控得觉得问题出在我们自己身上，正如我之前所说，我们被心理操控得觉得：不，我只是要把这甩掉。这只是我自己的反应过度。所以你需要从其他人——你信任的人——那里寻找并收集证据，让你能够相信自己的经历。所以去和你的朋友聊聊，和那些陪你度过那段时光的家人聊聊。然后说：你知道的，嘿，我有点怀疑当时真的有那么糟吗？而他们会看着你的眼睛说：不，那太糟糕了。你当时的经历客观上讲就是极其糟糕的。你完全有权利离开。你完全有权利一走了之。因为，你知道的，再次强调，
have been in that environment. We have almost been gaslit into feeling like it's normal. We've been gaslit into feeling like we were the problem, as I said before, we've been gaslit into being like, no, I'm just going to shake this off. This was just a bit overdramatic on my behalf. So you need to find evidence and collect evidence from other people, people you trust, that you can believe your experience. So talk to your friends, talk to your family who spoke to you through that time. And and say, you know, hey, I'm kind of doubting whether it was really that bad, and they will look you in the eye and say, no, that was terrible. What you were experiencing was objectively awful. You had every right to leave. You had every right to walk away. Because, you know, again,
有时我们身处那个环境中，几乎被洗脑了。我觉得有相当多的公司在这方面非常像邪教。我想到了Buzzfeed，闪回，你知道的，来自过去的闪回。但还记得Buzzfeed吗？当时它是个大事件。然后后来所有这些人都站出来说：你知道的，我曾经以为这是史上最好的工作，但它实际上极其消耗人、极其糟糕。有时当你身处某种环境中，能够坚持下去的唯一事情和唯一方法就是给事情涂上一层积极的色彩并将其美化。
sometimes we are in that environment and we almost become indoctrinated. I feel like there are quite a few companies that are quite cult-like in this way. I think about BuzzFeed, flash, you know, throwback from the past. But remember when BuzzFeed, it was like a huge thing. And then afterwards all these people came out and were like, you know, I thought it was the best job ever, but it was actually incredibly taxing and awful. Sometimes when you're in an environment, the only thing and the only way to get through is to kind of put a positive spin on things and to glamorize.
你知道的，如果你的大脑以及你完全清醒地意识到这段经历有多么糟糕，你是无法应对的。所以我们筑起高墙，我们进行区隔来生存。因此，请确保你理解你的反应是合情合理的。通过让生活中的客观人士为你证实这一点，你的反应也完全是恰当的。展望未来，我要在这里做一个说明：工作场所或工作是有毒的，这不是你的错，你并不罪有应得。
You know, if your brain and if you were fully conscious of how terrible the experience was, you wouldn't have been able to cope. So we put up walls, we compartmentalize to survive. So make sure that you understand that your reaction was valid. Your reaction was also completely appropriate by getting objective people in your life to confirm that for you. Moving forward, and I will caveat this by saying, it's not your fault that a workplace or a job was toxic, you did not deserve it.
但如果可以的话，从现在开始尽量挑剔一点。注意那些可能预示着一份工作正在形成某种不友好文化的警告信号。最大的警告信号是，当他们在招聘过程中——甚至在面试中——立即表现出对任何事都不愿妥协的姿态。他们在薪水上毫不妥协。他们在工时上毫不妥协。他们在居家办公上毫不妥协。
But try and be picky from now on if you can. Notice the warning signs of when a job might adopt. up to a certain culture that is unfriendly. The big warning signs are when they are immediately, like in a job application or even in an interview, I'm willing to compromise on anything. They're inflexible about salary. They're inflexible about hours. They're inflexible about working from home.
当他们，你知道的，自称是一个大家庭时。说实话，相信你的直觉。比如当你走进大楼或进行面试时，他们对你显得相当冷淡，或者你觉得他们——你知道的——面试你的人自己也才刚加入不久，这真的表明员工流动率很高。开始对你选择的工作挑剔起来。我知道这是一种奢侈。如果你负担得起花一点时间，通过人脉或任何方式真正努力去争取一份你非常、非常喜欢的工作，我认为从长远来看这是值得的。这是值得的，因为，你知道的，你不必
When they, you know, call themselves a family. When, honestly, trust your intuition. Like when you walk into the building or you have the interview and they feel quite disinterested. in you or you feel like they can't, you know, the people that are interviewing you with themselves have only been there for a little while that really indicates high turnover. Start to be picky with the job that you choose. And I know that this is a luxury. If you can afford to take a little bit of time to really try and secure a job that you really, really like through networking or through anything I think it pays off in the long run. And it pays off because, you know, you don't have to
觉得自己被迫进入另一份工作，而那份工作有着相同的经历、相同的氛围、相同的环境，然后六个月后你又回到了原地。这种机会并不是每个人都有的，但我确实认为，当我们离开一份工作、一个职业或一个环境时，这是一个极好的机会，让我们反思自己对工作的期望，并真正重新思考我们在工作方面的价值观。重新思考我们想要达到的平衡，特别是如果你得到了裁员补偿——那真是一份大礼。在我们的生活中，在我们的职业生涯中，只有极少数时候我们能拥有几个月的时期，我们可以仅仅存在而不必工作，可以去旅行，或者可以，你知道的，花更多的时间。所以拥抱那种奢侈，拥抱那种
feel like you've been forced into another job that's the same experience and that's the same vibe in the same environment and then six months later you're back in the same spot it's not always available to everyone but i do think when we exit one job or one career or one environment it is a really good opportunity to reflect on what we want from work and to really rethink our values when it comes to work rethink the balance that we would like to strike especially if you have a redundancy right that that's a gift so few times in our lives in our working lives do we have a period of months where we can actually just exist and not have to work and can travel or could, you know, take a little bit more time. So embrace that luxury, embrace that
经历，如果可以的话，就好好休息一下。好好休息。恢复精力，和朋友聊天，多花时间陪伴自己，重建你在这次经历中可能已经失去的身份认同。我想这就是我今天要带给大家的全部内容了。我想这就是我应对有毒工作场所的最佳建议。老实我知道如果你能感同身受，我真的很抱歉。我知道这非常、非常困难，但你并没有小题大作，你也没有过度反应。我希望我不需要再多说什么了，
experience and just take a rest if you can. Take a rest. Recovery, talk to your friends, spend more time with yourself, building back up, that identity that maybe you have lost throughout this experience. I think that that is all I have for you guys today. I think that there's all my best tips for handling a toxic workplace. I'm honestly quite sorry if you can relate to this. I know it is very, very difficult, but you're not being dramatic. You're not overreacting. I hope I don't need to say that any more than I already have,
但这确实是一段非常艰难的经历，因为在当今时代，工作是我们身份的基石之一。所以没关系。照顾好你自己。你会找到一份更好的工作。你会找到一个更好的工作场所，这一切都会过去的。如果你喜欢这一集，请确保关注未来的剧集。我们还有一堆关于“20多岁如何找工作”、“20多岁的职业焦虑”之类的剧集，
but it is a really difficult thing to go through because work is such a foundational part of who we are in this day and age. So it's okay. Take care of yourself. You will find a better job. you feel we'll find a better workplace and this will pass. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure that you are following along for future episodes. We also have a bunch of episodes around like finding a job in your 20s, career anxiety in your 20s,
如果你需要后续剧集来帮助自己，比如“如何找到自己的天职”，那可能会有所帮助。也请确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是@thatpsychology1podcast，并给我们发消息。如果你有任何反馈，对这一集有任何想法，或者你自身也有过这样的经历，我们很乐意听到你的声音。如果你愿意的话，请留下评论。请确保关注我们。留下评论会让我们的一整天都充满阳光。
how to find your calling if that's a follow up episode that might be helpful. Make sure that you're following us on Instagram as well at that psychology podcast and message. If you have any feedback, if you have any thoughts on this episode, if you've had an experience yourself, we would love to hear from you. And leave a review if you feel called to do so. Make sure you're following along. Leave a review. It makes our day.
我真心希望这一集能帮助你度过你正在经历的难关。直到下一次，记得保持善良、注意安全、对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的
I really hope that this has helped you through what you're going through. Until next time, remember to be kind, be safe, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our
科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在经历这一切后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-%”。在《回顾过去》播客中。对于1979年，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。通过我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家来讲述。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是个疯狂的年代。
strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survive. It's subscribed it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
那是个疯狂的年代。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难中学习》。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host's Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere. but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人随身携带着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难中学习》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
网络侦探大军花费了一番功夫才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。